Ukraine's defense ministry's warning
against navigation in the Black Sea it
says ships traveling to
russian-controlled Ports will be
considered as potential carriers of
military cargo a day after Russia
announced a similar move
okay let's stay with that story Russia
is insisting it's ready to return to the
Black Sea grain deal when sanctions
including grain and fertilizer exports
are lifted but Western sanctions extend
far beyond agriculture Russian banks
have been cut off from the global Swift
payment system and Central Bank assets
have been frozen Western Nations have
also limited their Imports of Russian
oil and gas and more than 1 000
International companies have stopped
working in Russia or joining us live on
Skype from Paris is marijuana bashara Al
jazeera's senior political analyst
Marvin good to have you on the show
despite all the sanctions that we've
just talked about and there are many
more from many other foreign governments
I was reading back in May the
international monetary fund is believing
that Russia's economy could actually
grow by 0.7 percent in 2023 this is
again going to open the question about
whether or not sanctions are actually
productive
well it depends what the objective is
all right I mean it could be a number of
things mainly they say the objective is
to affect change in the policy behavior
of the sanctioned country in this case
the Putin regime in Moscow but there are
also secondary and rhetoric uh goals
such as satisfying the domestic public
opinion such as making a stand or taking
a stand on the question of the war in
Ukraine but if if the question is
changing the behavior of the regime of
the government in Moscow certainly that
that did not happen it's not happening
the war continues and and the sanctions
are not affecting the behavior even
though the sanctions in this case are
not an alternative to war they are in
fact complementary to the ongoing you
could say War by proxy in Ukraine
but be that as it may though it it is
hurting somewhat but it's also been
hurting here in Europe let's remember
that this past winter wasn't easy when
uh when uh electric bills uh tripled in
uh in certain countries like uh you know
the UK or Germany and elsewhere so it
did uh hurt the Russian economy
apparently it did contract by two
percent last year and it could contract
by two percent this year but it has not
changed the behavior of the government
and it's certainly not leading to regime
change in Moscow given the subjects that
um uh Vladimir Putin raised with regard
to the the agreement to return to the
the Black Sea grain deal if these
conditions were met does that at least
give foreign governments the uh the EU
at the very least or the U.S gun some
idea of where for want of a better
phrase Russia might be hurting most I'm
thinking in terms of uh the Swift
payment system for banking for example
that allows International transfers of
funds as we mentioned before Russian
Banks aren't part of that clearly that
is an issue does this give those foreign
governments uh a Target if you like that
they know this is where these sanctions
are likely to have the greatest amount
of effect
well interestingly banks in Russia can
still deal with banks say in India China
Brazil and elsewhere so there is no
problem for Russia to deal with those
brexit countries that make up a third of
the world economy
what Swift makes it uh easy uh for uh
those transactions to happen what it
does is makes it more easier and more
secure and more fast for the
transactions to happen and clearly Putin
just wants to get rid of one layer of
sanctions there are almost now 10 layers
of sanctions against uh against Moscow
and this one is the easiest of all for
the Western Government if they decide to
follow on the Secretary General of the
United Nations recommendation and do
lift the sanctions especially to those
banks that deal with those kinds of food
exports it would be really within within
a very short time because unlike other
sanctions like for example energy that
did hurt consumers in Western Europe
This one is just really about how to
deal with global transactions among
Banks the Europeans established that
somewhat 50 years ago 1973 it's been
very effective and more than 2 000 banks
are you know members of that and all of
that and Russia would like to just get
back into that so it'll be more easy for
it to uh trade with the rest of the
world it would be the easiest for Europe
to lift if it really wants to it the
Europeans are not exactly excited about
that yet because they think this is
something that you know needs to stay in
order to once again
um you know change the behavior in
Moscow lead to the end of the war
the Russians on on that part of course
continue to insist that no matter what
sanctions are going to be important then
they're going to continue with more of
the same we've seen that not just with
Russia which is you know considers
itself at least as a as a global power
or at least a regional power of sort you
know a major source of energy and
nuclear power but even smaller countries
like Iran uh in the you know back in
1990s or Iraq or even Iran today Cuba
right it's a very small country we did
not change the behavior their behavior
because of sanctions so sanctions in the
scholarly world still a very
controversial uh policy right it's seen
more like as an Imperial uh instrument
by Western countries to impose on those
they don't like like in Iraq Iran Cuba
uh South and North Korea and Russia
rather than a real instrument that could
affect change to their defense the
Western countries say look we no longer
do
carpet sanctions right we're not meant
to hurt Russians or Cubans or Iranians
even if they eventually do so now they
call them more targeted sanctions or
smart sanctions meant against Banks
against corporations against governments
in order to affect change of policy
rather than to hurt people in the end of
the day they still hurt people here and
there and whether they are actually you
know functional and and reach their
targets as we were just saying it is you
know it's it really remains out there
it's controversial it's not actually
assured clearly the Russians are not
changing their policy so all in all this
remains controversial it is really part
of economic Warfare against Russia and I
think as long as the war continues they
will continue as well Marwan as always
thank you very much indeed mawan basara
Al jazeera's senior political analyst